tell me
[Applause]
two years after Tom Holland's epic lip
sync battle performance it was amazing
fun he's explaining why he won't be
dancing under that umbrella ever again
[Applause]
Spider-Man star recalls the routine
during a chat with The Hollywood
Reporter Tom says he's proud of it and
adds I like that it left a lasting
impact
[Music]
I'll be here forever
[Applause]
[Music]
remember Tom went head to head on the
show with his now girlfriend Zendaya in
2017.
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing
Bruno Mars okay yep Z nailed her Bruno
Mars impression but it was Tom who
shocked the world with his full-out
performance of Rihanna's 2007 hit
umbrella fishnets water choreography and
all
it's raining
[Applause]
most stressful thing I've ever done in
my whole career period
um but that said it was so fun the
ellipsync battle aired around the same
time their film Spider-Man homecoming
came out what are you hiding Peter
I'm just kidding I don't care bye the
Marvel star recalls it was an amazing
time my life was changing before my eyes
I was on top I was getting offers and
turning them down for the first time
which was really crazy you know I am
blown away but despite all that Global
success as an actor you can guess what
Tom says he gets the most love on for
all the movies that I'm incredibly proud
of the lip sync battle is what I get the
most compliments for I'm mean dude but
for Tom moments like that are all in the
past he explains you'd never catch me
doing that now just because I don't want
to do a TV show that I don't need to do
I'd rather go and play golf and live my
little private life I'm really really
lucky to be in this position and uh I
think it's important for me to just sit
back relax and enjoy it you know rather
than trying to cram in too much and I
just want to enjoy it while I can and
while Tom's moving away from epic lip
sync battles this gem will forever be a
part for pop culture history
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]